congratulations on joining season two of
condor the show has been
huge around the world yes um were you a
fan of the first season of the series
ahead of your casting and what do you
love about
it what i hadn't actually seen it before
my casting i'd heard about it i knew
that it was shooting here in toronto
uh i was uh previous to that i was i had
been working in
in ireland shooting vikings and so
came home had to catch up very quickly
as to what was going on
and i mean for one of the amazing things
about it
is we have three people in the show with
some of the coolest names
in all of hollywood we have max irons
which is just an amazing name
it's true max irons and then bob balaban
which is also an amazing name bob
balaman which is just fun to say
yeah i couldn't wait to get to work just
to say bob balaban
and then the amazing constant zimmer
which is another incredible name
awesome uh so not only are they have
incredible names they're they're
incredibly talented people and and
phenomenal actors and
and so getting thrown into uh the fray
with them
was uh was fantastic and it was shooting
in toronto so i got to be home
i got to spend the summer at home for
the first time in like
five years oh really yeah so it's like
you know toronto in the summer you wait
all winter to be able to have toronto in
the summer
and so i got to do all that and it was
uh
i mean the show was amazing the writing
was
uh was just phenomenal like we would be
in the cast read-throughs every week and
going
like the twists and the turns and the oh
my god i can't believe it this year oh
my god i can't believe you so it's
the show is secrets lies and spies
and it's just you don't know who whose
side anybody is on and it's all about
this
very big gray area of morality and what
makes something
right so it's amazing yeah it's it was
incredible fun
uh to do um and then to to work with
people with really cool names
so there's that so you're playing tracy
craven season two a cia officer but what
can you tell us about tracy who is he
um what does he bring to the second
season of the show
tracy is like the uh all-american
good guy coming in uh you know
they they know that there's a mole
within the cia
and uh tracy is one of the the rare
people who believes
in the the goodness of people or so it
seems you know he he really does want to
put the benefit of the doubt in people
uh and and and hope for the best and and
really not
doesn't wish any more pain in the world
because there's enough of it
um so he's he's in there to to root out
who the mole is
um and and uh you know
sort of guide max irons back into the
uh sorry uh
bring uh him back into bring joe back
into the cia
love it now i also understand that there
could be could be a love interest with
may in season two
what can you tell us about the
relationship and what can we expect in
regards to
that well uh i mean i can tell you there
might be yes possibly a love interest
with me in season two and i may or may
not
have something to do and it's you know i
think it's
the the at the crux is it's two people
who exist in this world where so much
cannot be talked about because
everything is so secret you have
you know this is government secret stuff
like you're not allowed to go and share
this stuff down at the bar with your
friends like you can't talk about this
so these
these two people find some solace in
each other being by being able to just
be open
and honest with each other so it's it's
a huge relief they've both gone through
some tragedy they've both gone
through some loss and they find each
other and it's it's uh
you know it's it's it's an honest really
it's a it's a lovely
lovely relationship and you know it
might not always go well
but you know the the root of where it
comes from i think it comes from a
really honest
lovely place love that is this a
difficult series to shoot i mean there's
a lot that's going into a series like
this
i there is challenges uh part of it is
you know keeping
you know the allegiances straight in
your head too of like where are we
like who's you know who's on whose side
and what do i know and what do you know
um and uh but it's like
some of the days like doing heavy stuff
like i found that as i got older these
these these harder scenes these darker
scenes being
being you know doing awful things
sometimes that
even good and bad characters have to do
it just hits me a little harder now it's
like stays with me
yeah it's not as easy to just walk away
from it like i find myself
like even after it's all done like not
necessarily wanting to watch those
scenes when they're on tv because it's
just like it's like ooh
i did that you know that that headspace
is not always fun to be in and um
so there's challenges like that but i
mean come on we have
uh you know we're blessed with some of
the best crews in the world
and uh you know so most of the time it's
just
shits and giggles and that's right it's
just you can say
it's good giggles it's that's uh yeah
so most important training did you have
to go through
uh how to tie my ties again you know
after being
in in vikings and uh you know using a
sword a gun felt a little
foreign to me yeah and uh definitely the
ties
you know it's like oh boy how do you
wear a suit anymore most used to like
more leather
yeah for sure for sure season two and
we'll deal with russia
can tracy be trusted in season two
i don't think anybody can be trusted in
season two that's what i
you know that's what i'm gonna say i
don't think anybody can be trusted
that's that's what i love about this
this season is it's
you really you really do get a chance to
you know when do the ends justify the
means like how far are you willing to go
to protect the people that you love how
far are you willing to go
for your own self-interest or where does
that lie where is that line for
everybody because everybody has that
line and this
i feel like this season is a bit of an
exploration of where does that lie
and what are the consequences of that
and how
how can you deal with the repercussions
afterwards
so it's a it's a very very dark slippery
slope we go down
you've had a really incredible career i
mean you've been on some of the best
series the biggest series
it's been nearly what 20 years since
smallville
uh came out looking back at that time
what did being on that series
do you think mean to your career
uh i mean smallville was um it was a it
was a bit of a phenomenon you know
it was you know i was only there in the
early days but like the early days were
some of the biggest hype
like this this was really the the dawn
of like
internet chat rooms as well and people
having their own fan sites and talking
about it and
i made the mistake of going in and
reading these things and like this
education in that regard and you know
but it's
like it's it's so funny like i'll meet
people who are in their like their 20s
or early 30s now and they're like oh my
god that was my favorite show when i was
a kid
and i'm like oh my god i feel so old
[Laughter]
but it was i mean it was awesome to be
part of like um
the superman uh universe and the
superman world
it's it's it's very cool i mean i mean
man i've made a career of playing
really awful people it seems like it
seems like every time i'm talking to you
i'm talking about this new awful person
i'm playing and it's literally
20 years so it's like next
it's got to be it's got to be you know
but i watched like that
i'll be the i'll be the jerk boyfriend
that she
that they ditched to go with the the
real good guy
maybe maybe it's kind of weird okay
all right well how about this do you
keep in touch with any of your viking
cast members
that show such a special place in all of
our hearts
it's uh it's a pretty amazing show
um you know i'll i'll text uh
i'll message adam copeland every once in
a while on instagram
uh who's like my first day on set on
that show i think i even said this on on
et
but i was like the smallest actor on set
and i'm six foot two
and it just i couldn't believe like oh
my goodness everybody actually
is really big here this is it's just not
the camera like people are huge
and they said to me like yeah just you
know you go run over and
pick up adam and i'm like i'm six foot
five 230 something pounds i'm just gonna
like pick them up like there's just
there's just no way
there's just i mean i love that show
we've got more episodes of that coming
out soon uh
i got episodes of american gods coming
out soon
and i've got condor coming out i think i
have like 25
episodes of television that's going to
drop in the next 10 months well this is
good because we all need it right we
need some stuff
right wait a minute though we did hear
there's a a special series
in development vikings valhalla would
you be interested in stepping back in
that world
if the opportunity presented itself you
know what i would be i would be like the
viking guy
making sandwiches for people like i'm
happy to do anything like that like
like i don't have to be the guy leading
the charge i'm like you you like you
need a guy
inviting sandwiches making sandwiches
like i mean they got to eat
you know they're going on these long
voyages let me pack you a lunch
you